Would it hurt to define of what a religious experiences in this case then?
Because I feel like the semantics of like,
I'm not sure if what you're saying about a religious experience is what I'm
understanding.
Well,
generally a religious experience is something like an experience of the,
of the renewal of the world.
That might be one way of,
of thinking about it so that everything's sort of leaps forward as crystal clean
and perfect as if you had been viewing it from behind the mask before.
Another would be a sense of the Union of everything.
And so you're a singular being and you're isolated and in religious experiences.
So for example,
there's a book written recently by a neuroscientist,
uh,
my stroke of,
what's it called?
My stroke of insight.
Yeah,
that's right.
And I believe she had a left hemisphere stroke,
if I remember correctly.
And she was
sufficiently well developed neuroscientists to understand what was happening as
she had the stroke.
And,
and she had a intense religious experience as a consequence of that.
And she experienced it as a dissolution of the ego into this state of union with
everything.
And this transcendent experience of awe and and the,
oh well I don't remember the rest of it.
I mean there are other elements of religious experience that are quite common.
The idea of the opening of the heavens,
that's one.
The communion with the ancestors,
that's another the reduction of the body to a skeleton,
that's another the movement up into heaven there.
These are well documented phenomena and a lot of them are associated.
While a fair number of them are associated with psychedelic use,
but that's not the only avenue to experiences like that and epilepsy can produce
experiences like that too and people usually report near death experiences as
well.
And you know,
people usually report that those experiences have life altering significance.
Now that in and of itself only proves that people are capable of having
subjective religious experiences.
Right.
It doesn't definitively proved that there's anything outside of that.
So Young Carl Young for example,
most of the time he didn't talk about God.
He talked about the God image,
which is not the same thing because you could have a god image that was even
evolutionarily instantiated without that necessarily being rep related to any
transcendent being beyond the image.
Right?
So who knows,
who knows?
Um,
again,
I think it depends on what you're willing to accept as proof.
Now the proof,
the it's beyond question that could,
people can have life changing religious experiences.
Another example of that is that the best treatment for alcoholism is religious
conversion.
It's well documented in the literature and I studied alcoholism for a long time.
So one of the cures that sticks is religious conversion and the 12 step programs
essentially attempt to instantiate religious conversion.
And it's hard to document their success because they succeed for the people who
stick with it.
But that's not a very good measure.
Right?
It's sort of,
it's sort of self evident that they work for the people who stick with it.
I'm not cynical about about alcoholics anonymous or anything,
but we don't have good data on,
on outcome.
But there is good data showing that religious transformation is a good cure for
alcoholism.
So,
and that's an interesting phenomena to um,
it's too complicated.
They're probably can't.
Okay,
I'll try.
I'll try this for a second.
So here's how I think a religious conversion might work.
So imagine you've got the left hemisphere and it's,
it's the place where your habitual interpretations reside.
So I can give you a quick example of this.
So this Guy Arama Shawn Ryan,
who's a neuro physiologist or a,
I think that's his,
that's his field of study.
I think he's at Ucla.
He studied people who had neglect.
And neglect is a very,
very bizarre phenomenon.
So if you have a stroke that damages your right parietal lobe,
you'll lose the left part of your being,
not just your body.
It's really weird.
It's like,
so for example,
if you have a right parietal stroke and you look at a clock,
you only see you only,
only half the clock exists for you.
It's not like you only see half the clock.
It's weirder than that.
It's that there's only the right side of the clock.
There's only the right side of you.
There's only the right side of my body.
I don't know that this exists.
And so sometimes people with right parietal damage,
we'll,
we'll wake up after the stroke and grabbed their left arm and throw it out of
bed and or their leg and throw it out of bed because it's not theirs.
And then of course they fall out of bed,
which is quite a shock to them.
So and so,
and they'll only eat half the food on the plate.
Nobody can really understand this phenomenal logically,
right?
Because we can't Magine what that must be like.
I think it must be like,
you know how you know there's things behind you,
but you don't not see them.
They're just not there.
It's not like it's black or anything,
or there's a space,
it's just not there.
And so I think what happens is the not there extends to three quarters of the
field instead of half the field.
That's a guess.
Anyway,
so Ramesh,
now,
the funny thing about people with neglect is that if you tell them,
if you point it out,
you say,
well,
I noticed that you're not moving your left foot today.
They'll say,
well,
it's,
it's arthritic.
And I can't move it and say,
well,
why don't you just try to move it?
So no,
look,
doctor already told you it's in too much pain to move it working fine this
morning and that can be months after the the accident.
So it's a denial and people thought actually that that was trauma induced denial
for a long time before they figured it out was actually a consequence of the
neurophysiological damage.
Now Rama Shondra and found that if you irrigated the contralateral ear,
say now if you pour cold water in someone's ear,
it upsets their vestibular system and their eyes will move back and forth like
this.
You can try that at a party if you want.
And
anyways,
Ramachandran was testing vestibular function on these patients and he irrigated
the right ear with cold water and they woke up.
And maybe what happened was that that was shocking enough.
So imagine the networks in the right hemisphere were degraded but not completely
gone and they needed a really high threshold of activation to snap into
function.
So here's an example of that.
If you have Parkinson's disease managing,
you're frozen there.
Okay.
And I throw a ball at you,
you'll go like this and catch it,
but you can't throw it back.
So you can,
the stimulus is enough.
That's enough to push you past threshold.
But you can't do it voluntarily.
Now if you have Parkinson's,
like right to the nth degree,
you won't even be able to catch it.
But there's a stage where you could still do that.
There's a great case study where this grandpa was in a wheelchair,
he had Parkinson's and his young grandson was playing out on the dock and fell
in the water and started to drown and he got out of his wheelchair,
went into the ocean,
rescued him,
brought him onto the beach,
sat back down in his wheelchair and was paralyzed again.
So that was enough.
So you can imagine there was enough network left.
So if the emotional tension became high enough that the degraded circuits could
still function.
So,
okay,
so back to remise Shondra so you irrigate the year,
all of a sudden the right hemisphere connections flash,
the remainders managed to connect and the person goes,
oh my God,
I've had a terrible stroke.
I've lost the left side of my body.
They're crying.
They're like completely catastrophic.
Lee overwhelmed by it.
And then 20 minutes later the they effects wear off and they snap back in and
now they,
they've lost her left side again.
They don't remember it.
And so what seems to happen is that the right hemisphere is collecting a
normalist information.
That's what it does.
That's what it does when you're dreaming,
it's,
it's representing that anomalous information in image form and sort of slowly
passing it to the left hemisphere so it doesn't overwhelm it.
And maybe if it gets overwhelming,
you wake up and you're afraid and you tell someone about the dream that helps
you figure out what it was.
But anyways,
so that the right hemisphere is always trying to tap the left hemisphere into
transformation,
right?
So now imagine that that can happen a little bit or a lot.
So maybe you're just ignoring a little bit of anomalous information.
You just have some mildly frightening dreams.
Or maybe you've just stacked up a whole bunch of things that you're ignoring.
And there's some major league monsters that you haven't contended with.
Maybe there's situations where the right hemisphere is stored up enough counter
enough of a counter hypothesis,
let's say,
about how the world works make making sense.
Out of all those things that you've ignored that one day it just goes snap and
you're a new personality and maybe the new personality isn't addicted.
So it's something like it's something like that.
I think.